[Music]
but mistakes make you strong
hey guys so what can you expect at a
model agency
interview well let me go and show you
let's go
[Music]
all right we're on the way to my agency
here in johannesburg south africa
they are called boss models and i'm
going to show you what a real model
agency interview
looks like let's do it
[Music]
okay
[Music]
all right guys this is balessa we're
here at boss models and she's going to
have a model agency
interview how do you feel i'm very
excited but i'm
very nervous all right we're going to
show you exactly what it looks like
if you come to a model agency interview
let's do it you ready go
hey guys hello
yeah yeah this is here you guys want to
come okay yeah
hi i'm laura i'm the director of boss in
johannesburg and this is deb
hi nice to meet you and we're gonna do
your interview today we're gonna take
off our masks because we
social distance six feet apart um so
tell me a bit about yourself how old are
you
what do you do um i'm 22 years old and i
recently graduated from university
and right now i just want to go into
modeling
what made you want to start i wanted to
be a model since i was a little girl
and this is something i'm really excited
for and
really nervous for today we love your
images
and we really would love to sign you and
we think you've got a great career
would you like to sign with her i would
love to thank you
welcome don't be nervous
it's all good it's going to be fine i'm
just going to check through a bit of the
process with you
and then we'll go through a couple of
the documentation things that need to be
sorted out we'll do some digitals
and some measurements and we'll be able
to hopefully get you started
okay and are you still studying are you
available full-time because that's not a
job that you can really do part-time
so you have to be available during
normal office hours from
9 to 5 because it's not something that
we only do on a weekend
so are you fully available to attend
your casting i am i am fully available
good fantastic um so there are just a
couple of things that we need to go
through
obviously when you join a modeling
agency in johannesburg you're not
allowed to be with any other agency so
you'll sign up to us
we will be what's called your mother
agency so we will essentially be your
mother within the business
so if there any issues if there are any
hassles if we need to place you anywhere
outside of johannesburg
in our durban offices or cape town
offices it'll come through
us and we'll do that placement with you
laura's in charge of doing replacements
at other agencies
and should international travel be
something that we look at at a later
stage then laura will also do that
we need to obviously get amazing images
of you otherwise we can't promote you
with clients
so you have to do a mandatory photo
shoot and there are a couple of
photographers a couple of choices that
we could go through
for you to have imagery done and based
on that imagery we don't make any money
out of training you
so the agency does train you for free
and
you pay the photographer and the makeup
artist and the stylist directly
so we only make money out of and
modeling
a model yeah if um you are working so
it's in our benefit
to get you working as much as possible
okay okay
and the training i will do with you so
you don't need to worry about
the fact that you're not going to know
what to do when you get there get stage
fright
so i will do full training with you we
do one-on-one training i'll teach you
what's expected when you actually go to
a photo shoot
from poses to the way that you relate to
clients
and then obviously things like going to
your castings as well what to expect
it's kind of like this um so you'll have
to get rid of the nerves
and but the more you do it the better
you become and that's that's my job to
help you do that okay
um have you done any form of acting
before at school have you attended drama
class
yeah at school i did drama pretty much
all of high school
okay good no that's gonna help for sure
yeah a lot
and what are benefits as well is we find
that
you have to convey a lot of your emotion
through movements and you don't really
have words to describe how you're
feeling so you've got to show it through
your face and your body movement
so it always helps to do a group acting
class
and it also helps to do dance classes so
content free jazz or
just give it a try so if you ever feel
shy
those kind of things really help you in
your posing so we'll help you find one
of those
so some of the information that we're
going to need is just obviously your
personal
information your name age id
things like that we have the new popular
act that everybody needs to sign
which gives us permission to hold on to
that information we need your banking
details
email addresses your instagram um also
things when it comes to instagram
there's
quite a new way that the modeling
industry is moving towards clients on
more
interested nine models instagram pages
more than ever before
so there'll be a couple of rules and
regulations there as well when it comes
to what you can post what you shouldn't
shouldn't post
obviously just to look after your career
going forward
and then things like your skills whether
you play an instrument
bungee jump bus ride things that have
set you apart from 20 other models in
the room yeah
so that's all the information that's on
the signup forms that will do
and then obviously i need to do your
measurements yeah um
the industry i think was so lara will
will content to that that
the industry's moving a little bit more
away from your
typical model frame um and body shape
but i need to have the sizes so that i
can let the client know
what your sizes are so they're no
surprises on the day
there are certain industries that still
require you to be
certain measurements and that's all the
shows internationally
have always required that um but the
catalogs and stuff
are a little bit more unique when it
comes to they just want
really healthy fit bodies you have to be
able to be in a bikini costume
at any time part of your job is to
go to gym make sure that you keep a
healthy body
and make sure that your skin is always
perfect make sure you don't change
anything about your appearance without
discussing it with us first because
that's going to make
a huge difference to your portfolio and
it could be quite expensive if you have
to actually shoot it
and yeah because we're going to do a
photo shoot looking the way you do now
so i'm going to
style you and set your portfolio up
those are the images that will go to
clients
and then clients will expect that same
person to actually rock up on the day
so you won't be able to do piercings or
change your hair
or have tattoos or anything don't look
at me
or me i waited 40 years to do themselves
okay
but you won't be able to just do them
without actually approaching the agency
first and discussing it with
us because we're selling you as a brand
and the client will expect that same
person when you know when you get to set
um
and then don't expect to know everything
overnight
um we're gonna help you as much as we
can we'll bring you in and we'll do
classes here with you we will show you
how to pose
these different kinds of poses every
country has different kinds of styles
we're going to teach you all of that
catalog poses are incredibly different
to editorial poses
all the lingo that you're going to need
we will teach you too
the other thing that laura will have a
more serious discussion with you about
once you sign all the documentation is
the financial side of things
you're obviously opening your own
business essentially from today
and you need to look after your finances
for your future know what money is
coming in what money you need to spend
to improve your book which is a constant
thing that needs to happen the whole
time so
it's always better to know what you're
earning and where you can spend that
money because
one photo shoot as beautiful as it will
be will not unfortunately not be able to
carry you for endless time
so we'll have to update imagery all the
time the other thing that i do which is
part of my job is to get you
as much time in front of the camera as i
can so i have a lot of people that work
with me
little phone i'm asked to do
collaborations with models stuff that is
free
but i will never recommend anything
unless i know that it's going to benefit
your portfolio
so i will be on the other side of the
phone telling you that there's an
opportunity for you
and you may not get cash for it but the
monetary value will be in your images
which will be
what will get you the next jobs and
hopefully you'll start earning the big
money from there
and our industry is typically feast or
famine
so you're going to get a lot of money
and then no money and then a lot of
money so you're going to have to learn
how to budget it
and live off a certain amount every
single month
like you would but you're going to have
to manage that
yourself are you pretty good with money
i am actually
it's good otherwise i'll show you how to
be good with money
i will go through the breakdowns the
taxes that you have to pay each country
is different so when you start traveling
i will go through
each country's regulations with you too
um
and it's always easier to show you once
you've started earning money how the
commission structures work how the taxes
were
within south africa all cool do you have
any questions
um when do you start
okay now now we'll sign the documents
now
so basically what will happen is that
you'll sign all the documents fill
everything out we're going to go off and
do some measurements
and then we also have our photographer
who does digitals and videos for us
so you'll go and do that with her now
digitals are really for
us to be able to send to clients should
a client turn around and ask
what palesta looks like without the
editorial imagery and everything behind
her what does she look like as the role
model
so that will be in bikini with high heel
shoes and that'll be up at the top of
our studio so we'll do those which we
keep on record
to send to clients and a short video so
the video is more about personality it's
to kind of pull the client in so that
they want to carry on looking at your
portfolio
and then we do the proper photo shoot
which will be set up within
10 days we then do the photo shoot you
get
20 to 30 edited images of which we will
then choose with lara
to go onto the website and we will make
the z card for you
yeah do you know what a z code is i
don't okay z card is a
business card that you're gonna leave
behind but the egg clients need to be
able to see what you look like
so there's a picture of you on the front
and then your details on the back with a
couple more
variants of showing you smiling what
your body looks like so we try and show
them as much of what you can do
in the front and back of a car okay and
you'll need that everywhere in the world
that you go
so that's what you need to test for um
i want to just come back to the
instagram thing again um
[Music]
yeah it is your digital cv and it is
becoming something that
clients are wanting to look at so i
always say to the girls
if you're not happy to have your mom or
your grandmother see something on a
billboard in jobaccentral
don't post it on instagram because it
will come back and buy to the bum at
some stage
i think it's good too if you do film
some behind the scenes to
show the producer onset or the direct
onset
what you've taken and then ask them if
you can post them
because a lot of the times their story
is confidential and
they don't want it out in the public eye
so just be very aware of that
and also yeah just make sure that
you etiquette things like if the makeup
artist is doing your makeup
don't hold your phone and be holding
your phone in front of her little do her
job
um when you get onto set greet everybody
it's the
basic commentary to see that a lot of us
have forgotten and don't
exist
yeah and if you see a stylist or
somebody
needs help carrying equipment in and out
or clothing in and out
it doesn't hurt to offer to help so
people we find that models
get rebooked because of how nice they
are to work with not about how great the
images are only
so a client will want to use you again
because it was such a good experience
for them to work with you
and then also things that models
definitely do not do
you never complain about the clothing
the client the makeup
the situation obviously if your life is
being put in danger or you are being
forced to do something that you
really are not wanting to it's a simple
phone call to your bookers
to say this is what's happening and i'm
uncomfortable understand our job to take
over that discussion
but never to express your anger
or your disgust or your distastefulness
with anything
to the client it is an
industry where you are representing not
only
your agency as boss but the client at
that moment in time
so the client doesn't want to know that
the makeup doesn't suit your face or
that the clothing looks horrendous as
far as they're concerned it's
their clothing it's their product and
they want it to be showcased as the best
way that it can be
so that just that being said if you're
ever in a situation that you're
uncomfortable physically you have the
right to say no
so you have the right to stop the shoot
and give us a call and we will always
make sure that you're protected
so but you don't have the right to tell
the
stylist that you want to be dressed in a
different way or to change your makeup
or you prefer your makeup or be done in
a different way then
that is what we're referring to and then
also
things i always say to the models do not
sign
anything on set anyway when you go to a
casting it's a different story they're
going to give you a clipboard like this
and they're going to ask you for your
name and your agency and a couple of
details of yourself
whether you've done products that are in
competition to where you're going that
sort of thing is fine it's standard
everybody does it
but when you're actually sitting on set
and someone runs around with clipboard
and says just sign here everybody's else
has done it don't worry about it
take a photo of it on your phone just go
to the bathroom
and send it to myself or to laura just
to ask the question
you don't know what you're saying you
could be signing your life away without
really knowing it so
i always say to the bills don't sign
anything unless it's come through the
agency first
and then the other thing as well once
you become a boss model
you are going to be inundated on your
social media with people who are going
to want to
shoot with you stylists photographers
makeup artists people wanting to give
you stuff for nothing if you just please
post
on instagram for me none of that is
allowed without coming through the
agency first
we just want to make sure that you don't
reach any other contract you currently
have
and we need to read through any
paperwork to make sure that you
like debra said it's not signing your
imagery rights away because
that is all negotiated in a contract by
the agency upfront
so once you onset that all the paperwork
that needs to be signed is already
signed
so anything after that is overriding
what we've
originally agreed so never sign anything
ever and when it comes to photographers
wanting to work with you
a lot of them will say will approach you
personally
which is fine they can but it needs to
come through me i bet
absolutely every single photographer
stylist makeup artist anyone who wants
to do a collaboration
i need to also make sure that you're not
working with the wrong people for the
wrong images for the wrong reasons
i also have a model release form that
all the photographers and stylists etc
on set need to sign
and that will stipulate that they can
only use the images for their social
media places
pages and for your social media pages
because the minute something is
advertised it then becomes a job which
has to come through the agency and then
keys are discussed
so without that happening without your
understanding of that
you might very well make an arrangement
to shoot something with a photographer
and a couple of weeks later we find that
you're advertising something in a
magazine or online
that would have been a fee for you yeah
so everything needs to come through me
and then i will give you the permission
to be able to do it
so we're going to do measurements and
then i'm going to send you off to don't
have your digital stuff
all right are you excited kind of
nervous mostly but yes
the more you do it the better you'll
become just remember everybody started
brand new yeah nobody knew what to do
when they first began
and look at them now so you'll be fine
and we are a family we take care of
our models we're all mothers in the
industry and we've been in the industry
for years i think
accumulatively in the agency we've
probably got over 100 years of modeling
experience so we've all been there and
done it
um you know laura's been behind the
camera in front of the camera
she knows the business she's done
booking i've been in industry as well
for my whole life and also remember
serena williams didn't
start on a tennis court and land up
winning and open
so it's not going to happen with you
either so you need to start at the
beginning
and work your way up to the beginning
okay
we're very excited to have you and um
yeah welcome to the boss family we're
looking forward to it
fabulous thank you you gotta sign i did
look everything i would have given you a
hug but yeah congratulations thank you
so you ready i'm ready i just need to do
some measurements now
to quick shoot and that's it i see and
she's already on the way to
give you those measurements so you can
put your bag down i need to take your
shoes off for me i'm going to do your
hype first
and then we'll do the rest of the
measurements here and then i'll take you
through for the tipples okay
okay cool do you guys mind if i hang
around a little bit no not at all
yeah it brings memories back you do your
thing
all right so just pop your shoes off for
me that we can get accurate measurements
all right so just put it back here for
me
okay 174
174 shoes
welcome to boss my dear thank you
all right so i'm going to take you
through to tamika and then she'll do the
digital so you can put your shoes back
on for me because we're going to have
that
nice elongated legs for the [ __ ] all
right super
okay so this is where the magic happens
hi tamika
nice to meet you
thank you um i'm going to leave you into
me with capable hands
we're going to do a short video of you
which to me will probably take you
outside to do bit of a street thing
i want you to play be animated smile
really kind of get your personality
across in the video so tamika will do
that and then you guys will come back in
here and then i need you to put your
black bikini on with your heels
and you'll go up to the outside studio
and tameka will then do digital's review
the digitals are going to be front back
side a couple of poses just really
basics
and she'll instruct you as you go as to
what you need to do
all right so i will leave you ladies to
it okay
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
looks like you've been modeling for 10
years already
[Music]
all right guys thank you i'm gonna run
i'm not gonna touch you but if i could
have would have given you guys a hug
let's see see you guys next time
you